- Si ces trois jeus s Ukrainiens
ont choisi Terre-Neuve-et-
Labrador comme refuge pour fuire
du nom de la province.
Mais depuis leur arrivée,
ce sont plutôt les mots
tout leur sens.
Au-delà de son nom invitant,
la province a multiplié
les efforts pour attirer
Elle a été la première à nolisee
à ouvrir un bureau temporaire
en Pologne pou
ceux qui ont fui l'Ukraine.
Et le gouvernement n'est pas
seseul à vouloir faire sa part.
Ce Terre-Neuvien a créé un
groupe Facebook
aux réfugiés ukrainiens,
qui compte aujourd'hui
plus de 17 000 membres.
Un divan à donner,
des emplois disponibles;
y sont publiées chaque jour.
Une démonstration d
l'hospitalité et de la
générosité qui fontvivivivivivi,
selon Michael Holden.
Et ces démonstrations,
on les voit un peu partout.
sa carrière de barbier loin
de lguguerre et qui reçoit
des pourboires de la part
de Terre-Neuviens qummmmmmmmmmm.
Lesa Winsor fait probablement
partie du 90 %. Avec son groupe
de tricot, elle a amassé 1500 $
et un panier de cadeaux pour
"Nous devons tous faire
quelque chose poureses aider",
explique-t-elle.
- You can't go wrong withalalal,
because they love it.
- Ça, Michelle Delaney l'a aussi
bien compris. Elle a accéléré
son appartement pour accueillir
ces oiois jeunes locataires
ukrainiens.
Et il n'y a pas que les
Labrador veut attirer.
La provinc q qui a la population
la plus vieillissante au pays,
souhaite accueillir 5100uxuxuxue
d'ici 2026.
Une solution qui s'imposepour e
de ce salon de barbier,
où les can
Serhii sont rares et précieux.
Michael Holden espère quasososk
ne sera bientôt plus destiné
qu'aux Ukrainiens, mais plutôt
à tous les immigrants.
Un souhait partagé par
ceux qui ont pu profitersososos.
Et qui promettent déjà
Ici Mathieu Papillon,
Radio-Canada,
Saint-Jean de Terre-Neuve